for
he has no any reasons to block Ukrainian
membership in EU and I asked him to tell
me one reason not three five 10 tell me
one
reason I'm waiting for
answer
we are talking not about only Ukraine
and the war and the Russian aggression
we are talking about our future I have
no doubts and it's uh my role here today
to
to to strengthen the determination
European determination and I think about
the EU as a whole but also I'm talking
about some member states you know to to
to to convince them that this is
something the the most important thing
for us as a Europe to to support
effectively Ukraine I will try to find a
maybe a new key to to convince not only
Mr Orban prime minister Orban as you
know and I
know that prime minister
Orban is very pragmatic
politician and uh please treat it as a
compliment I'm very much hopeful that
Hungary will also change its attitude
towards the European perspective uh not
you know so much for the Western Balkans
because as you know Hungary is very much
supportive of the western Balan European
perspective but also when it comes to
the Eastern neighborhood I think that
the choice of the Ukrainian people is
very important and you all know that
Ukrainian people want to be the part of
the of the EU ultimately as it stands
for Montenegro it stands for Ukraine as
well it is ultimately a merit based
reform oriented process that we are as
the country as Montenegro committed to
and I truly believe this is what all the
other candidate countries are committed
to uh this will be a long and difficult
week the enlargement process shouldn't
be held hostage to other demands uh the
decisions we reach at the end of the
week should uh advance European
Prosperity peace
stability
uh the world order rule-based world
order as We Know It uh the conclusions
should not favor moscow's interest
that's an important Focus if uh when
Hungary became a member we have asked if
Hungary was rich enough to be member of
the European Union maybe Hungary
wouldn't be a member today so it's also
solidarity it's to to make potential out
of of Partners and also democratic
values and um but I'm not on the market
you know I don't want to I had that I
said that already a few years ago we are
not on a Suk here to say you give I take
it's uh and we don't fix the price it's
rules and we have to stick to the rules
uh if there is a vetto I just would like
to understand why there is a vetto it
has to be a Justified vetto and I'm
still waiting
for real reasons and not
the other reasons we are in full solid
it and support for Ukraine we just want
to have uh seen a clear and fair
approach to all member states and future
member states and when we are talking
about the accession process then we have
to see that there are different
standards um when it comes to Ukraine
and mova and when it comes to bosan
heroina so we want to see them in the
same boat if there is a political
strategic decision to start the
accession negotiations uh with Ukraine
and all then we should also start the
negotiations with bosnan and
heroina